[Music]
hello and welcome to this episode of
what's a Prof G Welter hi Martin we're
going to talk about questions again we
haven't done that in a long time so yes
and some people think that you know why
don't you get Dr to it we have a a
full-time Ministry answering questions
by the way that's it and uh there are a
lot of questions that are answered on
our web and through uh trusty faithful
workers that are answering questions on
a full-time basis so you really try and
keep up with this but there are some
questions which
are sometimes a little bit baffling yeah
and it's good to do it in a public
setting
so that a lot of people can get the
answer yes and let's just say we're not
sages we might get things wrong too
because it is a it is a big learning
curve but uh you know if you if you have
a little bit of experience in this
business
then God will will provide wisdom and
answers so let's seek his let's seek his
help will you pray for us well well
before we pray I can just maybe put a
advertisement in you yes uh pretty soon
um hopefully if everything works out we
are planning on having a series where
two uh very uh capable speakers will be
addressing quite a lot of questions yes
questions and maybe testimonies and
interesting things so we're trying to
expand the Horizon a little bit to try
and accommodate all of these things
where people really have problems or
also to encourage people yeah yes
because WhatsApp Prof is very much
geared to presenting the information
that is necessary for the times that we
live in mhm providing encouragement Pro
trying to provide biblical answers to
many of those questions questions as
well but uh we have to stay orientated
as to where we are in the Stream of time
and at the same time how we should be be
preparing for what is lying ahead yeah
so we need a little bit of another
another Forum where all of these other
things that we don't have necessarily
time for or a slot for can be addressed
yeah so we're looking forward to it and
um please keep all this in our in your
prayers yes so let's open with a word of
prayer yes we can't do without it our
heavenly father it's a privilege to work
for you and we need you more than ever
especially in the times that we are
living so now when we discuss some
questions and important questions please
enlighten our minds and help us to go
through all of this in Jesus name amen
amen well Martin it's true that we work
for God but uh if he doesn't work with
us we're totally
lost so maybe we should say to work
together with God you remember our
previous one cooperation
cooperation all right so we've had a
couple of questions from the
viewers and these are things that
recur so let's see if we can address
some of them okay so our first question
can I baptize myself why why is it that
only pastors can baptize if the Great
Commission says that we should all go
out to teach and
baptize yes I've met many a person that
thinks that they are you know quite
happy to
baptize out of their own
valtion God is a god of order isn't he
oh for sure all right now if you go back
to the early
church when somebody was specifically
called for a specific purpose let's say
Paul who from a persecuting person
became a believer in Christ and then a
great teacher mhm when he was sent in to
give him that Authority didn't the
elders lay their hands on him yes so the
elders laid their hands on him and
commissioned him to go and do this great
work that's it maybe we can just make it
clear that it wasn't some magical thing
that happened with the laying of the
hands there no it was a blessing spoken
over was seeking God's blessing and
giving a demonstration that this person
had been
selected by the church leaders to go and
do a specific
task and Paul baptized yeah because it
tells us in Acts chapter 19 that he came
to a place and there were people that
hadn't heard about the baptism of the
Holy Spirit and he felt that it was
necessary to re-baptize them after they
had been baptized according to the
baptism of John the
Baptist and therefore he baptized them
into this new knowledge because the the
holy spirit is the one that testifies of
Jesus yeah so they were baptized into
this whole truth and he baptized them
all right so who baptizes and why cannot
just anybody
baptize if you are
chosen by God to do a specific
work then somehow you will become
associated with his church right that's
it and within that setup when you are
recognized as a specific worker then you
will be empowered to do so you will
become a deacon mhm and the church will
bless you and lay hands upon you and uh
you become a deacon or you become an
elder yeah or you become a pastor or you
then become an ordained Pastor yeah or
an ordained Elder and an ordained Deacon
right so these are the posts that that
show that the church has
confidence in your ability and your
sincerity in terms of these things yeah
now if everybody were just to
baptize where would we go what would you
baptize them into is everybody
acknowledged by the church
officially as having attained a
certain
status in terms of your belief that it
is trustworthy enough and that you live
according to the principles so that you
can be incorporated into the system
that's why there's a structure Jesus and
God put the structure there yes and so
within this framework of the church
there are certain
positions now who may baptize in the
Adventist Church for example Well
normally it is the pastor that
baptizes but an elder can also
baptize if he receives the authority
to do so so it's an application he asked
may I in this particular case
baptize and because he has this
particular association with the people
or whatever the reason may be and in
most cases the church will not have a
problem with an elder
baptizing but if the pastor baptizes
then it is obviously acknowledged by the
whole church that the person being
baptized has been vetted as to being
taught everything that is necessary so
you cannot have everybody just baptizing
because you don't know what that person
taught MH you don't know what the
understanding is of the one that is
being baptized and are they representing
the truth as it is in Jesus that's
because the Bible says that you must
teach them and then baptize them yeah I
mean even the part where Phillip was
with the unoch yes he first went through
the scriptures okay the unoch was
already studying it and then they went
through it and after that he asked him
what prohibits me from being baptized
yes so all right so we've answered
basically the second part of the
question the first part of the question
is can I baptize myself well what does
the baptism stands for it stands for the
death and the resurrection right the
resurrection into to the new life and so
you are buried yeah and raised mhm who
raises the dead Jesus it is Christ so
this is a symbolic Act of the death of
the old person and the resurrection can
you resurrect yourself no only God can
only Christ can resurrect you so when
you are dead can you become alive of
your own valtion no no there has to be
another entity namely Christ that gives
gives you that life and calls you into
the living the new life the life in the
spirit so you cannot baptize yourself
because you cannot resurrect yourself
yeah so the pastor symbolically stands
for the one who takes you out of the
water yeah so when you get buried the
old person dies and he is resurrected by
Christ into a new life and if you go to
Jesus's baptism
himself
he well if we take it he was actually
supposed to baptize him himself but he
said to John you have to to get this
whole in order to fulfill all
righteousness because he became sin for
us he who had no sin became sin for us
and therefore his baptism is the perfect
baptism and therefore when I follow by
being baptized my baptizm is recognized
as perfect through his perfect baptism
not through my perfect baptism through
his perfect intercession on my behalf so
I cannot baptize myself I've had people
that have tried to do that or actually
did it baptized themselves but of course
it's not recognized as a baptism yeah
thank you so second question can you
help me understand the correct meaning
of 1 Corinthians 15 vers verse
29 all right let's read verse
29 else what shall they do which are
baptized for the dead if the dead rise
not at all why are they then baptized
for the
dead now this verse has produced much
confusion in the the world in fact
terrible confusion and there are whole
church bodies that baptize for the dead
MH and even baptize the dead yeah yeah
all right it's where they believe that
they have the power to baptize the dead
so let's let's go to one Corinthians and
see if we can find out what this is all
about because you have to read it in
context yeah true true everything always
it's not just glancing over a scripture
a text and then that's a All gospel no
you have to you have to read the context
and whatever you read may not contradict
any other portion of scripture that is
very clear on a particular issue the
state of the Dead for example what
happens when you die the Bible is very
clear if you are dead you know nothing
the dead know nothing they have no part
in anything that takes place in the
world so what is this all about so if we
go to chapter 15 which is quite a long
chapter and I think we should start with
verse 12
okay now if Christ be preached that he
rose from the dead how say some amongst
you that there is no resurrection of the
Dead that was the
problem Christ like the
Pharisees taught that there was a death
and there was a resurrection of the Dead
the Sadducees did not believe in the
resurrection so what did the Pharisees
believe they believed like most modern
Christians believe yeah namely that you
die die and you become a spirit entity I
understand all right now Jesus clearly
taught the resurrection from of from the
dead yes he did but he also demonstrated
it by raising people from the dead like
Lazarus for example now that must have
totally dumpfounded the the
sades but this philosophy is
so prevailing it is so all consumed in
that people and all Pagan Nations
basically believe that when you die you
go directly to another world yeah or you
become an energy or you become an energy
or you become a soul or that the soul is
a separate entity we'll talk about that
in with another question in a
moment but this was the issue so now if
Christ be preached that he rose from the
dead how say some amongst you that there
is no Resurrection from the dead but if
there be no resurrection of the dead
then Christ is not
risen
so everything hinges on the
resurrection because the wages of sin is
death mhm and death according to the
scripture is a state of non-existence
yeah you are dead you know nothing you
are sleeping yes if the Bible is it's
actually so clear it says those that
have fallen asleep correct those that
have fallen asleep so the resurrection
is pivotal to the Plan of
Salvation Jesus says I go to prepare a
place for you and when I go to prepare a
place for you I will come again so that
you may be where I am also only then
yeah only then and then there will be a
resurrection so when the churches teach
this interim
State then you have a problem because
it's not scriptural so what's the point
when you go directly to heaven when you
die and then you have to come out of
your grave and go to heaven again as
what as a you know are you going to be
it's so confusing are you going to be
reunited with your soul what is going to
happen and what's the point of it all so
basic basically he says if there be no
resurrection of the dead then Christ is
not risen verse 14 and if Christ be not
risen then is our own preaching Vain and
your faith is in vain if Christ is not
risen that means there will be no
resurrection of the Dead this is the
issue that's the problem there was a
false teaching is there a false teaching
today yes so it's very many actually not
even just one if you drop down to verse
17 it says and if Christ be not raised
your faith is in
vain ye are yet in your sins because
then there's no salvation then we're
dead that's how it
works then also they which are fallen
asleep in Christ or
perished yeah in other words your entire
hope your entire
faith is vanished it's gone it's
vain if in this life only we have hope
in Christ we are of all men the most
miserable yeah because then you don't
have any hope further than does life I
might as well have stayed an atheist
right and just enjoy it enjoy life and
get on with it but because we have faith
in a future life we must have faith in a
resurrection that's what he's saying so
the resurrection is pivotal and Christ
if he didn't R rise from the dead dead
is not who he claim to be and cannot
raise you either perfect do not work
okay then we come to verse 20 which is a
new paragraph in the Bible now he's
going to un unpack this
idea and he says but now is Christ risen
from the dead and become the first
fruits of them that
slept so if Christ didn't rise from the
dead then you and I are lost
it is because of his
resurrection that anybody can live or
anybody has the opportunity to have
eternal life for Since By Man Came Death
by man also the resurrection of the Dead
referring to Adam that sinned for as in
Adam all die even so in Christ shall all
be made alive but every man in his own
order Christ the first fruits afterwards
they that are Christ's at his
coming it's very clear it's very clear
there is no Resurrection until the
second coming of Christ between yeah so
there is no Spirit entity floating
around until the coming of Christ there
is no such
thing then cometh the end when he shall
have delivered up the kingdom to God
even the father when he shall have put
down all rule and all authority and
power and then he continues to say
everything will be under his feet MH so
the godhead God the Father gave all
authority unto the son all judgment unto
the son everything will be under the
feet but that doesn't mean that God the
Father will be under his feet and he
argues that God the Father gave the
authority Etc but the point is when the
Resurrection comes then God's people
will be with him and he will have
established the
kingdom now let's drop down to verse
29 which is the problem verse
here else what shall they do which are
baptized for the
dead if the dead rise not at all why are
they then baptized for the dead and why
stand we in Jeopardy every
hour now what does it mean when he says
you are baptized for the dead because
surely you are not baptized for the dead
no when you are baptized you are dying
to self and being resurrected in Christ
so what does it mean it actually means
baptized to be resurrected with the dead
eventually in other words because you
believe you will be part of the kingdom
of of God you will be
reunited with your brethren so let's say
now you have someone that is very dear
to you and that person
dies right Y and then you discover the
truth that this is just a sleeping
situation yeah and you follow Christ do
you have a hope that you will be
resurrected and that you will meet that
person again 100% okay so you will be
baptized to be reunited with the dead
that's it yeah that's basically what it
means we'll all rise together to be
reunited with each other all that are in
Christ will be reunited yes and from
what we've read earlier he's as Paul is
also now asking if Christ did not rise
what use is there
and then even being baptized there's no
point in it there's no point you are
waiting for the resurrection from the
dead yeah but not only you as he said
there earlier but at the coming of
Christ all that are in Christ will be
resurrected so you become part and
parcel of that group that will be
resurrected that's what the ver means so
you are being baptized with a hope that
you will see Jesus come correct and come
and fish read it in any other
way then you get a confusion which
contradicts everything in the Bible
because then the dead no longer sleep no
and you can there must be actual
entities that move around God forbids it
the H of spiritism yeah will become a
truth rather than a lie Purgatory
because now you can pray for the dead
Purgatory becomes a reality if you want
it it does it's not in the Bible but but
if you choose to invent it you can use
verses like this and become totally
confused but the Bible is very clear
yeah it says in verse
23 but every man in his own order Christ
the first fruits afterwards they that
are Christ at his coming so nothing
happens before then no and Jesus did
rise so you can be baptized to be risen
spiritually to wait for him correct
okay all right so that's basically what
it
means thank you let's see what else
we've got all right here's another
question Martin what is this all about
okay well the following has been said in
interviews and in conversations relating
to celebrities and magicians and Etc
that they have sold out or have sold
their soul to the devil I'm trying to
reconcile this statement with Genesis
2:7 all right Genesis 2:7 says and the
Lord God formed man of the Dust of the
ground and breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life and Man became a
living Soul continue with this yeah so
can the Soul be bought or sold seeing
that God is the one who puts a breath in
man so he becomes a living Soul or is it
a misuse of the terminology Soul also
how do you explain when someone astral
project what part of the human being is
separated from the physical body in that
experience all right this is a mouthful
mhm but it links actually to the first
one that's why it's good to put this one
in now firstly why is it necessary for
these kinds of questions to even
arise because the world out there has
been so confused as to the state of the
Dead yeah that they they mingle the
error with the truth and it's not
anybody's fault that's how you grew up
yes now the Bible is very clear as to
the state of the dead I don't think we
have to go into a big study no but the
fact of the matter is you are a living
entity because this person rightly says
over here that this verse is then
contradictory to everything that these
people are saying
so the Lord God formed man of the Dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and Man
became a living Soul he didn't receive a
living Soul that's so important he
became the living
Soul we say so many Souls were baptized
so many Souls died yeah it's not the
spirit it's not a separate entity the
human being is the
entity and and this Breath of Life this
Ru this Spirit as it is often
translated is the metabolism the fact
that you are breathing you are a living
entity you are the living entity you are
not a shell for a living entity that's
what the the verse says and that's
exactly what it says so when you have
sold yourself to the
devil you have sold your whole life over
to the devil your cognitive thinking
everything everything you have said that
he's you belong to him yeah basically
you have given yourself a death
sentence for the benefit of a temporary
short life of wealth and luxury maybe it
can explain when I said earlier you just
might as well have enjoyed your life
that is enjoyment according to the
worldly
then you don't have a future longing for
a better life no now I think we showed
some videos of some of the mega Stars
where they admit that they sold their
souls yeah for the sake of temporal
Advantage right yeah and it's a very sad
State of
Affairs because to sell your eternal
life for the sake of something like that
is horrendous yeah Esau did it Y and
Esau sold his Birthright now the
birthright doesn't only refer to the
temporal
inheritance it refers to the whole
future life to the eternal life the
Eternal inheritance it is your
Birthright to be part of the kingdom of
God that's it all you have to do is meet
the conditions you didn't want to meet
the conditions he sold it for a pot of
potage yeah the same with these Stars
they the same with them they sold so
actually so just to make it plain again
they didn't sell a spirit of them or the
the ghost the ghost they sold their
whole life so in other words if they had
a correct understanding they would
realize that they have no eternal life
they will be as though they never were
that's what abadias says the de will
consume away they will be as though they
never were they will be in the state of
non-existence that's what they will be
in so can the Soul be bought or sold yes
you can sell your future inheritance
eternal life to the devil and then you
have eternal death together with him
because that's his his uh portion as
well okay so it's it really is a misuse
of the terminology Sol
then the question continues also how do
you explain when someone astral
projects what part of the human being is
separated from the physical body in that
experience now I think I'm a little bit
qualified to speak about that because
before I became a
Christian I actually practiced astral
projection now that seems uh very
strange to some people people there's
specific techniques that you can use to
astral
project and one of them is to create an
oxygen
shortage so you stop
breathing and uh eventually you go into
a hyper State and then you are separate
from your
body now is this a reality or is this a
hypnotic thought or hypnotic pattern
that has been introduced into your
system yeah I think that one I can
remember standing next to my body
looking down at my body and then
frantically trying to get back into my
body and jumping and jerking that I fall
right out of the bed and lie on the
floor and waking up and waking up and I
had experiences which were amazing yeah
I could go through walls I could do all
of those things I could travel to other
planets to other
entities and there was always this sense
of
floating of moving in the air and you
always connected to your body by what
they call the silver
cord now is that a real experience or
was it an hypnotic implant the answer is
it comes from an oxygen shortage in the
brain and that oxygen
shortage uh cuts out your frontal lob
your
reasoning ability and then something
takes over and plants an experience into
your mind okay so there is a spiritual
side to this
spiritual side but it is demonic and
that's what we haven't touched on this
yet no through all of this we it's
important to
realize the dead sleep but there is also
a spirit world there is a spirit world
that takes over and implants ideas and
thoughts into your mind can God give you
a vision yes all right so it gives you a
vision mhm and then
this whole
scenario appears before you yeah and you
experience it as a
reality but in actual fact you are still
down here in this earth and sometimes
when you return from that experience
when you read what the prophets have
written then it's a very depressing
state that you're coming back to yeah so
this euphoric state is
something that can be induced God can do
it can a demon do it yes yes he can give
you false Visions exactly and false
experiences and they are implanted in
your mind and when you wake out of that
circumstance you can relate them as
though they really
happened but they weren't real they were
implants mind implants so never does the
soul because it doesn't exist as a
separate ENT entity separate yeah same
with near-death
experiences you have these experiences
of going through light tunnels and
they're all very similar why because the
devil has a very similar doctrine that
he wants to implant in people's minds
that is so important to remember so
that's why there are tests biblical test
to see if that is true or not okay so
the Bible says it's not true and you are
experiencing it it must you take the
experience or must you take the word you
see so it's important because if you
remember quite a few years back there
were the Christians that were having
sances and then eventually the Angels
told them to murder yes to kill certain
people yeah and then you must know
because it's again to the law and to the
testimony you have to test the spirits
that's where it comes exactly so this is
a very very dangerous game and I'm
afraid it takes place on many levels mhm
and it's going to increase this is one
of the last deceptions that will come
all right now how many people in the
world are committing mass murder because
some entity told them that they have to
do this we read it over and over and
over in the news and the more people
give themselves over to demonic
influence the more this will happen in
the world MH so we can expect many many
manifestations we can expect many
experiences we can expect uh actual
meetings with Spirit entities yeah but
we must know that the dead know nothing
that's it that the dead are asleep so
when these things happen we must know
that they are demonic so when any
relative deceased relative of yours
appears to you and tells you anything
you must
know the Bible says the dead knows
nothing correct and if you have this
Vision experience which they call astral
projection then you must know that this
is a
demonic situation the vision itself the
implant is
implanted and the environment in which
it happens is induced by yourself m in
harmony with demonic forces that's it so
be very careful yes thank you let's see
what else we have got I have a question
regarding Ezekiel 40 as I understand it
this chapter is describing that new
Temple in the New Jerusalem at the end
times and it serves also as a literal
description of the Israelites as to how
they are to build the literal Temple the
parts that throw me off are verses 38 to
43 where he talks about sacrifices and
preparation of sacrifices my question is
why does it talk about sacrifices and
preparation of sacrifices when there
will be no sacrifices or death in the
New Jerusalem and the new
Temple all right so Ezekiel 40 you have
the story we don't have to go through
the whole thing but basically Ezekiel is
given a vision and now remember Ezekiel
was one of the Exiles he was outside he
was part of those that were in Exile so
he was the one who was to encourage the
Exiles so he was in Babylon with them
yes Jerusalem had been destroyed the
temple had been destroyed and now he
gets a vision of the temple and an angel
is measuring the temple he's got the
measuring rod and he is measuring it
exactly and it is described that this
entity that is measuring is very bright
it's like golden brass and and beautiful
so they're measuring the temple now we
must understand that this is not
necessarily speaking about the temple in
heaven that is being measured no but the
measuring of the temple is a type of the
measuring of the people that comprise
the temple mhm cuz there's a spiritual
aspect and you have to measure up yes
you have so that you don't weigh not
weighed and found wanting correct now at
that stage when this Vision takes place
Jerusalem was destroyed so there were
two aspects to it to give a reason as to
why it was destroyed they never measured
up but it was also given as an
encouragement that it would be rebuilt y
so you can use the data to say this is
how it must be rebuilt because it gives
very exact
measurements and uh it also tells you
that you must shape up so that this
doesn't happen again now we know that
the temple was rebuilt and that it was
again destroyed again yeah in 70
AD and that it would never be rebuilt
because it was a type of a spiritual
Temple that was made up of living stones
that have to be built into it some often
must you measure up yes and I must
measure up if I want to be Hune and
squared in the Quarry of Life yeah I
must be queued and squared so that no
Hammer will actually be used when I'm
built into the temple yes once you're
there you must be right all right so
that is the projection to the Future
state so this this is a very symbolic
vision and it's very confusing once you
start literalizing it and asking
yourself the question why were there
sacrifices well at that stage Christ
hadn't died yet no he was still
foreshadowing it yes so in a future
Temple there would be sacrifices that's
what what it was all
about so the sacrifices were weren't
referring to what was happening in
heaven it was referring to what was
going to happen and how you must
appropriate this perfect sacrifice and
therefore it gives many verses exactly
what the tables look like how the
sacrifices were to be washed in other
words be meticulous in your faith and
understand the
typology as to what it means and how to
incorporate it into your own life that's
it and then after after that when Jesus
came then the spiritual side get kicks
in correct so be very careful to make
these things absolutely literal thank
you let's see if we have another
question well on Jeremiah 35:2 the
person asks would you kindly expound on
the story of the
recites why were they told to drink wine
in the house of God okay if you go to
Jeremiah
35 let's let's take the Bible
good all right so let's first just talk
about the recites in
general Martin if we go to chapter 35 it
tells you what was to happen there to
the recites or what was Jeremiah
supposed to do with the recites now they
were kenites they were related to Moses
M's family the
midianites and they had made a vow not
to drink
wine and uh they drank no wine because
they got this uh injunction from their
forefather and they promised not to do
this ever so you get to chapter 35 and
it says the word which came unto
Jeremiah from the Lord
in the days of Joakim the son of Josiah
king of
Judah
question Jeremiah Was he living in a
time of great faithfulness in Israel or
a time of great apostasy in Israel very
much great apostasy he was living in
great apostasy and the poor man had had
a very hard time right yeah he didn't
have it easy all right and now he gets a
strange instruction a strange
instruction instructions often given in
the Bible yes especially to Jeremiah all
right he had to do some very strange
thing like bury his loin cloth and then
go and dig it up and the Lord said Put
it
on and it's a relationship that God is
trying to depict in a very very
picturesque way he says my relationship
with you is as intimate as if you were
my loin cloth yeah all right it can't be
any more intimidate than that but you
are so apostate so don't bury it until
it rots and now put it on that's th and
Jeremiah I'm not going to do that so the
Lord is trying to say to him or trying
to say to the people you expect me to
take you back yeah and this is what you
are doing and I'm constantly taking you
back it's an enacted Parable yes I
remember we did that all right and there
were enacted parables in in the life of
Ezekiel yeah he was told to bake that
strange bread with with the strange
heating utensils that he was supposed to
use so there are there are very deep
lessons in any of these things so here
was this group of
people that had made a
vow and they were very meticulous to be
faithful to that
vow so they were very akin to what we
might say Nazarite V like John the
Baptist who was also not to drink any
wine and Jesus said I will not partake
of the fruit of the vine until I am
reunited with them so Jesus himself is
now under that kind of vow yeah now
let's go then to the story so
Jeremiah in the face of this totally
apostate Israel is given the
instruction and the word which came unto
Jeremiah this is verse one from the Lord
in the days of yakim the son of Josiah
king of Judah saying go into the house
of the
recites and speak unto them and bring
them into the house of the Lord into one
of the chambers and give them wine to
drink so this is an enacted
Parable and it's it's very very
interesting
then I took yzah the son of Jeremiah the
son of
habah and his Brethren and all his sons
and the whole house of the recites and I
brought them into the house of the Lord
into the Chamber of the sons of Hannan
and he goes on and on the man of God
which was by the Chamber of the princes
which was above the chamber etc etc and
then he goes to verse 5 and I set before
the sons of the House of the rec ites
pots full of wine and cups and I said
unto them drink drink you the
wine what do you think they would
say would they be surprised oh for sure
yeah they would have what what you doing
right kind of expression so the next
verse I always love this word in the
Bible but it's very it's very
informative the word
but they said we will drink no wine
you're wasting your time giving us wine
what's the matter with you become
apostate what's wrong with
you for janab the son of recab our
father commanded us saying ye shall
drink no wine neither ye nor your sons
forever neither shall ye build and gives
the whole ritual of what he shall not do
and how they will be faithful and in
verse 8 thus we have obeyed the voice of
yadab the son of recab our father in all
that he has charged us to drink no wine
all our days we our wives our sons nor
our daughters we won't do it I forget it
isn't that a beautiful enacted Parable
yeah so he's saying okay tell them to
drink and they say we won't do way now
you've promised me in the past that you
will be faithful to the Covenant mhm are
you faithful to the Covenant is
yeah are you're doing this look at these
people the answer is no you're not doing
it now look at these people I will tell
them here the Lord says here drink and
they say no so IM if somebody comes to
you and says something to you and says
no it's okay you can do it the Lord said
so exactly you can break the Sabbath
it's okay Jesus broke it so you can do
it as well what about the prophet that
said no it's all right you can turn
around and eat with that person didn't
that person die M the Lord doesn't
change his word did he go and inquire
Lord did you really send this man to
tell me that I can go back no he never
he just took his word for him you see he
said I'm also a
prophet oh I'm also a prophet so this
was an example to Israel listen why
don't you act like these people yeah to
this day they are faithful to a covenant
which they made to a human being their
father how much more so should you be
faithful to your heavenly father when
you made a promise to him yeah yeah it
was an enacted Parable so the
command that was given here was
ignored they didn't go along with it
even though it came from the hands of
Jeremiah yeah it was a demonstration of
steadfastness exactly it's actually
beautiful
yes may we be found so faithful yes May
our promise to
God not be broken because of someone who
says it's no longer binding amen and
maybe we can just put it in there there
will be in the
future many attempts many attempts and
even entities that will say
oh maybe Satan himself when he puts
himself as an angel of Light will be
saying I told you you can you can this
law is not so yes
bad okay and next question my question
is even if you fully own the land how
will one pay Council rates on the land
if one cannot buy or sell well I have
the same problem Martin so it's my
question too the answer is you won't be
able to that's it and they So
eventually they either so busy that they
don't get to you
or they kick you out the and if they
they do then that is God's problem right
that's it so what do you do in this case
you have to pay rates and you have to
pay all of these expenses and now
they've closed your bank account and you
cannot do it anymore and they say you're
in a r we're going to kick you
out you know I know of people that have
had similar
problems and the Lord looked after them
yeah and if it's in his will that you do
not live there then anymore you you have
to have the faith and all of that to
trust him that he will take care of you
in another place he will take care of it
so the bottom line is always do what you
can yes and leave the consequences
there's no use sitting there and say ah
this is not going to work in any case no
you should do what you can so that you
have to stick to what is right and leave
the consequences to God so I'm not going
to compromise in order to be able to
stay if they kick me out it's
temporary the Lord has gone to prepare
something better amen it's temporary
very nice okay let's go on please help
me understand this verse and then 2
Chronicles 15:13 we'll look at now I
learned from your show the word type and
antitype is there an antitype to this
verse all right 2 Chronicle
15:3 that whosoever would not seek the
Lord God of Israel should be put to
death whether small or great with a man
or woman now what happened here was the
prophet came to encourage
ASA again Israel was in deep deep
trouble and they
repented they repented and they
consecrated themselves holy unto the
Lord and they got rid of all the idols
again they cleaned the house you know
what they periodically did so under this
situation they were cleaning house and
they said whosoever would not seek the
Lord God of Israel should be put to
death whether small or great whether man
or woman everybody on board please yes
let's take this to the end time scenario
let's
say we know that the end is coming
because legislation has been introduced
that makes void the word of God yeah and
the law of God then everybody who sees
this knows that this is the crisis hour
and you have to make a decision you're
either with God or you're against God
right yeah and everybody that is with
God
stand by what you believe and you will
face the ey of the devil he will
threaten to kill you he will threaten to
take away your house he will say you
didn't pay your rights and taxes he's
going to Hound
you absolutely as far as he can push it
yeah but you have a promise that God
will take care of you and you make a
stand and you stand with God mhm and not
everybody does that some say no this is
not going to work for me what's going to
happen to those people eventually then
will be they will die die they will die
they will all right they will die
because when the Lord comes and you have
made your decision to rather accept the
mark of the beast than to suffer and on
the side of Prince Emmanuel you will die
so here's a great
typology that whoever would not seek the
Lord God of Israel should be be put to
death whether small or great whether man
or woman it's going to be a consequence
in the end it is so and this was a
typology that was a typology once again
it's almost an enacted Parable again yes
because and the other thing that I was
just thinking when we were speaking
about this is it also when you have to
be faithful in the big but also the
small things because when there's things
coming over your path
like we spoken last
week White Lies a small thing it can
also keep you out from where you should
be yes you have to be absolutely
consecrated and if you're not in the
last days then the consequences will be
death and the Bible says why will you H
die oh House of
Israel choose life that's it choose life
the outcome in the end will be the same
as it was here yes so many of these
questions are actually related yeah and
you have to
understand the the typological
aspects and the end time components the
eschatological aspects otherwise it
doesn't make any sense especially like
we've mentioned the Old Testament
because always the Old Testament is a
foreshadowing or is very much an Parable
or like you mentioned here it can be
applied especially with his let's say
judgment this is a form of judgment it's
a form of judgment that's what will
happen this will be the
consequence right next question this
person quoted Deuteronomy 14: 21 you
shall not eat of anything that dieth of
itself Thou shalt give it unto the
stranger that is in thy Gates that he
may eat it or they may sell it unto an
alien for thou art a holy people unto
the Lord thy God Thou shalt not see the
kid in his mother's milk so the question
is Martin yeah why were the Israelites
permitted to give to a stranger what
they weren't allowed to eat themselves
yes that's a that's a interesting
question so they weren't allowed to eat
anything that
wasn't uh killed according to the
standards that God had given them so
some animals died for example when
another animal GED
them so let's say two bulls were
fighting one died it wasn't slaughtered
according to the biblical principles the
blood wasn't drained etc etc and here
was now a loss or it was an unclean
animal they w w't allowed to eat it now
what was the correct thing actually to
do the correct thing would be that uh
you don't pass it on yeah that's the
correct thing to do so was it a correct
thing to do for
example uh in Samaria where they were
raring pigs yes they were raring them
and selling them right who were they
selling them to to the Gentiles to the
Gentiles and they were probably saying
well we're not eating them we're selling
them to the Gentiles we're just making a
bu or two here what's wrong with that so
this is a practice that Humanity has
done all along mhm so let's say for
example you realize that certain things
are
unclean let's say certain marine life
crayfish or something like that is
unclean and you have a crayfish
industry or you own a liquor
store and this is how you make your
money but the Bible says woe to those
who give drink unto their neighbor to
make them drunk etc etc so you have a
problem once you accept the truth
basically you should give these things
up but the world is a
reality and they were doing these things
so
now what God did is he realized what
they were doing and how they were doing
things and he permitted certain
things for example he would say you may
sell that
animal but you may not eat it it would
be best if you explain to that person
why you won't eat it but they may eat it
exactly because that was the purpose
that you were given is teaching others
yes you were supposed to be a good
teacher but they didn't do it in
anything
they were
divorcing their wives by giving them a
piece of paper with a scribbled note on
it as to why they should be left and
they said to Jesus Moses permitted this
mhm and Jesus says it was not so in the
beginning so in the beginning you
wouldn't even eat any of this right of
course none of it to go back to what the
diet is supposed to be none of nobody
would have eaten it so God
realizing the consequences of sin
and the
broad uh applications that they were
going to
be allowed certain things which weren't
in themselves
right because of the hardness of your
heart that's it it's one of those issues
there one of those issues way today if
uh a farmer shoots an
animal that is a pest for
example and he himself doesn't eat that
kind of meat but uh the laborers eat it
or the other nations eat it or even
relish it for
example uh then that's just part of the
world today there are nations in the
world that eat dogs would you eat a dog
M no definitely not no but there are
nations that eat it it's just a
reality so in Africa this is a very
common thing things die things uh die
because of whatever because of
altercations with other animals or
whatever and people will eat it but the
Bible says you may not eat it yeah so
that is where you draw the line that's
where you draw the line in fact it will
just be better to go back to the Eden
diet and teach somebody else that as
well yes and uh practice what you preach
and don't expect others to transgress
what you know is right true that would
be the best way to go okay thanks let's
move on to another
question please help me to reconcile the
apparent contradiction about what Alan
white says about bringing Christmas
trees into the church and the following
verses Jeremiah 10:1 to5 and Deuteronomy
12:30 especially the verse in
Deuteronomy isn't bringing a tree into
the church at the time of Christmas
doing likewise well so let read
it okay all right let's go to
Deuteronomy first because he says
especially Deuteronomy take heed to th
thyself that thou be not snared by
following them after that they be
destroyed from before thee and that they
are inquire not after their gods saying
how did these nations serve their gods
even so will I do likewise careful that
you don't do that all right that's the
one let's go to Jeremiah
10 Jeremiah 10:
1-5
hear ye the word which the Lord speaketh
unto you a house of Israel thus says the
Lord learn not the way of the Heathen
and be not dismayed at the signs of
Heaven for the Heathen are dismayed at
them for the customs of the people are
vain for one cutteth the tree out of the
forest the work of the hands of the
workmen with the axe they deck it with
silver and with gold they fasten it with
nails and with hammers that it move not
they are upright as the palm tree but
speak not they must needs be born
because they cannot go be not afraid of
them for they cannot do evil neither
also is it in them to do good now the
word the verse in Jeremiah talks about
fashioning an idol out of a tree yes so
that's one that you so that's a
different
connotation Deuteronomy says don't
follow the nations of around now
Christianity had become accustomed to
the celebration of Christmas
M so it became a ritual in
Christianity so in the Christian sphere
this was part of the
tradition tradition is a very hard thing
to get rid of
yes and then you have these statements
in the spirit of Prophecy where it says
that uh you can bring a tree into the
church
MH and it's hard to reconcile this with
the knowledge that Christmas is a pagan
Festival so let's let's start from a
very basic premise
Martin was Ellen White aware of the fact
that Christmas was celebrated
incorrectly yes very much so right there
are numerous statements where she says
Christ was not born on the 25th
yeah and there are many statements which
says we may not do the way the rest of
the people do it exactly all right but
she did say you can bring a tree into it
but then she qualifies it and says is
there anything wrong with bringing a
plant into a church don't we bring
flowers into a plum into a church yes we
bring flowers into a church is there
anything wrong with with bringing
flowers into a church yeah all right but
Martin what if you were to bring roses
into the church it'll be fine because
God created the Roses yeah but you have
the rosac crucian order where the rose
is dedicated to Lucifer why would you
want to bring a rose into the
church because God created the rose the
fact that Satan swiped it for his own
purposes doesn't make it his in any
shape or form so if I want to bring a
rose into the church
ignoring his claim to the
Rose then that's fine right yeah and if
I wanted to bring a fern Leaf to augment
my rose display would that be a problem
no it won't so really there's no problem
with bringing any kind of plant into it
now the Christmas tree is normally
packed with gifts mhm to gratify whom
well to get gratify man all right right
so you are all excited because you're
going to shower yourself with gifts or
shower someone else with gifts so in
this scenario Ellen White says no do the
opposite if you bring an offering bring
it for the poor not to gratify yourself
so basically what she's saying is
whatever they
do do it in a different way do it in an
opposite way okay that was the Christian
mure and this is how it all started yeah
that was in the Christian will year like
you said right and it was very deeply
entrenched in her time interestingly
before her
time when the the settlers came there
was a point when they actually banned
Christmas as a pagan
Festival but that had gotten lost and
Christmas had again being Incorporated
and was very much part and parcel of the
experience so here Ellen White says all
right you can you can bring a tree in
because there's nothing wrong with a
tree loaded with gifts to God and to
serve the poorer people but not to
gratify self do it
differently okay so Christmas itself
Martin is it a pagan Festival yes
completely yes but it had become a
Christian tradition right yes they had
the date wrong they had everything
everything was wrong about it
so let me ask another
question is knowledge Progressive yes
okay so the spirit of Prophecy is quite
clear that it's not Christ's
birthday and as it became clearer over
the years that there were serious Pagan
connotations many many people became
aware of the fact that Christmas was
actually not a Christian experience yeah
right
true is it wrong to speak about Jesus
and his birth on any day of the year no
so there are also hymns in the hym book
that acknowledges the birth of all right
so are you not allowed to sing A Hymn
acknowledging the birth of Christ no not
at all you can you can all right can you
do it on any time of the year yes all
right but let's say now for example it
becomes very clear and many many people
begin realizing and the information gets
out there that Christmas really is a
pagan
festival and therefore it is not so
offensive anymore to say let's not
celebrate it at all would you agree that
you could get to that point you can well
I'm at that point I understand the
context of what is going on here that's
why you set distance yourself from the
way way that the world is doing it m but
as the world becomes aware of the fact
that there is no reason to celebrate
Christmas on that particular day then go
a step further and say I distance myself
from it yeah and then so I don't
celebrate Christmas at all mhm true and
then you can also use it to reach other
people bring them to the truth to bring
them to the truth so it is a question of
taking note of the circumstances of the
time in which it was done the health
reform message was it Progressive yeah
definitely the church started off
without the health message M then the
health message was
introduced it was very hard yeah it took
some to get the message through and uh
fortunately then everybody accepted it
and everybody was totally happy with it
right no to this day it is hard to get
the message through the same with
Christmas Christmas that's it thank
you uh that brings us to another Point
Martin when you celebrate any of these
festivals or anything it is customary to
do what the world does for example
bringing candles into the church
lighting the candles and all of these
things like in in Many religious systems
there is a
Great Value attached to lighting a
candle etc etc none of that is necessary
in true
Christianity true Christianity is based
on a relationship with Jesus Christ
that's true and you know when the when
the reformers started to preach the
truth then uh the Roman Church
particularly in the time of hos it
started off already
they forade them to take part in any
ritual and they thought that by getting
rid of all the rituals in the church
that they would destroy the services
yeah but in actual fact they became
deeper because they were concentrating
on the word rather than on the
paraphernalia that surrounded it that's
true because that's there's more
attention given to some paraphernalia
than actually the meaning of what the
all all is about
let's take this back to
Christmas if on the so-called Christmas
day which is no Christmas day you give a
sermon on the birth of
Christ but refer the mind or divert the
mind to the fact that Christ is no
longer a bab but is the great high
priest who is soon going to take off his
Priestly robe put on his kingly robe and
return to this earth wouldn't it be a
means to divert the mind to the present
reality it's like you also said on that
in that time or especially on that day
take the people to his second coming to
the second coming rather than to the
birth yes the the the devil will be well
pleased if you stay focused on the babe
in the
manger and not focus on the king of
kings and Lord of lords that is coming
to receive his people I'm looking
forward to that so you close off please
let's close with a word of
prayer heavenly father there are so many
things and so many problems and so many
hooks to hang your doubts
on let not our minds be diverted by all
of these things let us concentrate on
that which is present truth and present
it to the people in the power of the
holy spirit is my prayer in jesus' name
amen amen
[Music]
in